all right and let's start with how long
have you two been married
we've been married 18 years 18 years
and ruth told me it was an arranged
marriage so talk to me about what
happened 18 years ago where were you
living
and what went into it i was in lahore
pakistan
and um he was visiting from the states
so he was a fellow in michigan
an oncology fellow yeah i was just
finishing my training
and uh just come to visit my family
in the spring vacations and uh
back home to pakistan so our families
know each other but we had never met
before
um our families know each other really
well and usually like when he would
travel back to pakistan that was the
time that his mother would then
you know propose show him certain
proposals so that's how it works
so he would like you know there's like
almost like a list and then
you know it's like oh so these are
eligible suitable girls that you can
consider
so i wasn't on his list i've been coming
no for the last for the two or three
years you know ever since i got my
uh residency my mom was trying to
hook me up but each time i would escape
you know so i thought this time i would
you know
come back to the states free again but
you know i guess i
laid eyes on her and that was it so if
you weren't on the list then how did you
two end up meeting
well our his aunt uh she is a friend of
my mom
so his aunt told his mother that aisha
is now old enough to get married so
consider aisha why don't you go and meet
them
and then his mom called my mom and they
came
came over for tea that's like the
traditional way of doing it
and yeah the formal interviews had been
concluded
so this was just added on at the last
time
for him yeah yes so his formal interview
of other girls
yes i know here in the us it's not
typical per se and
uh how do you think though having this
marriage that
i guess arranged in marriage because i
mean there was still choice in the
matter it wasn't like
you two are getting forced to married
start a life
there was choice and you two did go out
on a few dates
we didn't go out no
that would be kind of frowned upon i
think it with the chaperone maybe
so uh no i we would just call it love at
first sight
it was kind of faith too our families
families knew each other very well
so you know the backgrounds were fairly
similar and compatible values are the
values were the same
and then you know the schools that we
had gone to we're in the same city
same social circle so we kind of knew
you know
had a fair idea uh but beyond that
um you know i do feel that
it's uh you know hit and miss even after
you date
for a while you know the statistics are
not that great here
in the us either you know uh
so i guess that if there is a fair
amount of
you know uh compatibility
that has been kind of pre-screened or
pre-arranged
and then you know you you have your
choice so
uh i did come for dinner you know
a couple of days later yeah yes that's
when
you know they they it was finalized by
the parents and us that okay
so let's go ahead and get married so
that
came over for dinner but yeah it was
very like quick
so how long between seeing each other
for the first time
until your wedding day uh we were
officially married a week later
but uh it's called the nikka so it's
like a
it's like a ceremony and it's like a
paper marriage and then you have a
reception so the reception was eight
nine months later
and we had arnica which is officially
you're officially husband and wife
so if you want to then break up the
relationship then you actually have to
go through divorce
so that's the process that our families
chose
that they're like they're not gonna
break up they better not break up
and so yeah and then we got married we
got the reception was eight nine months
later
got it and 18 years uh
children as well two children correct
three so we have a 16 year old daughter
and we have a 13 year old son and we
have six month old son
what's the secret to maintaining
you know the love the relationship and
you know continuing this
together i would call i would say
number one thing is respect and then
commitment
you know loyalty love love grows over
time
and um absolutely you know you you
said everything so the only thing left
is i i feel that
you have to encourage each other for
uh individual growth yeah help each
other grow
help each other obviously the happiness
of the couple
is tied to each other so the goals need
to be aligned
but the individual growth should not be
overlooked
for each partner and i think that's
where the real happiness comes
in that you don't necessarily have to
give up
something that you really
truly want to do or want to be just
because
just because you're married so and
i mean that is tough you know you both
of
both the couples you know you have to
you know sacrifice for each other
and that lends to the strength of the
relationship so
so basically i mean like when i saw him
i you know i had a crush on him he was
like this handsome
man and he went to all like that's all i
knew about him i liked his family and he
was
[Laughter]
you know so all the criteria were
fulfilled
so i had a crush on him and then over
time you know it
you know became love and then i you know
as you grow up and you understand what
love really means um so yeah
so it takes time that's why i don't you
know whether you date or not i think it
just takes time to really get to know
the person
uh a lifetime really so so
would you encourage arranged marriages
i would think that uh it should be a
balance like you know so
arranged marriage is basically your
friend's family uh
telling you hey you know this is a nice
person you should consider
uh i think your friends and family know
you maybe even sometimes better than you
know yourself
so i think that's a good prospect to
start with and then
like you know like you said that perhaps
maybe like go out or get to know the
person a little bit
um if you just don't know anything about
um so i think it's a balance
that we should all work with that is
correct i think
arranged is not uh forced or obligated
like we see in the movies that you know
you just show up and your parents tell
you go sit there and they're gonna get
married
that i don't agree with
you know you have to spend your life
together so
you know i had you know my parents or my
mom had like
pre-screened like i said the last two
three years so
i had you know met and you know gone and
to the
you know meet the parents and the
families
uh for quite a few times so
i had a fair idea that you know what
what i'm getting into
and then i mean unless there is really
a deal breaker you have to work towards
the relationship so yes i think that a
little bit of
uh pre-screening or compatibility
does help uh although you know it can be
argued
both ways yeah you know i don't think
you should be limited to
to to just having arranged marriage but
you know suggestion by loved ones
parents who know us
uh you know sometimes a lot better than
we know ourselves
at a younger age um
i think does help yeah because i think
that if you like fall in love and you're
really young then you just you know how
they say love is blind so you can't see
the weaknesses or anything of the person
so i think it helps when you have
your loved ones kind of watching out for
you yeah i'm suggesting
and um you both are from pakistan
yes is that typical arranged marriage
it is it is typical there so now i think
i would say
it's it's 50 50 now yeah it's changing a
lot
uh but uh yeah it's still considered
typical
which pakistan india okay okay and
would you want to go about the same
process for your children
like i said the balance so you know so
we'll like suggest
uh prospects to them that we think may
be a good match
but ultimately it's their decision uh if
they want to go ahead with it or not
which is we just want them to be happy
and it was your decision in the end
right i mean yes for us it was very
quick
yes so and also i think for our children
they are a little different from us
because they're
born and raised here so
their background or temperament
may not necessarily match up with
someone who grew up in pakistan
you know so uh
so those factors have to be i think
uh acknowledged uh and i think just
being close to your children and kind of
you know
yeah i'm taking their input is the key
anything you would like to add it is
valentine's day
just about uh what's the secret to
uh successful marriage and any tips
you go ahead so again i would
say that you know the love and respect
each and every day
is not the valentine's day you know uh
would be ideal and uh you know
cultivating the friendship
and again uh you know cherishing
each other's individual growth and being
part of it
uh yes i think that we should just you
know
you should move in the same direction as
a couple but you should have your own
independent
um dreams and ambitions as well and each
should support
uh the other so that's how i think that
once you're like dependent on the other
or you know then resentment builds so
you should pursue your own passions and
goals
and the other partners should be
supportive
so that's number one and then of course
respect love loyalty commitment
and after you two were married uh when
did you come to the us
2003 so yeah so
i had been here since 99 so i was
already doing my training so once we got
married then you know after about
eight months or so uh then she came over
so 2003.
so i had just done two years of college
and so like we were talking about being
supportive
so he you know i finished my undergrad
after school
i had my children during school then i
went to law school
and graduate school and he was
supportive throughout
and then you know and now i'm pursuing
my career as a healthcare attorney here
in town
and i don't think i could have done it
without his support
so i think that's number one and even
i think what has made her the
happiest is you know from being uh
[Music]
dependent to being independent and then
you know
she has reciprocated that support in a
significant way as soon as she was done
you know with all her training she put
her career on hold
and then we moved we had just moved to
las vegas so she
helped and her you know background
helped us tremendously in setting up
my medical practice and she was
part of it for about four or five years
and what do you um if you don't mind me
asking what do you both do
so i'm an attorney i do healthcare i
practice in the healthcare arena
and he's a medical oncologist got it
okay is there anything else you'd like
to add or
feel like we haven't touched upon oh i
think it's great to be
you know the opportunity to represent
yeah
yeah thank you absolutely and i know you
said you moved
raja you said you were here and you were
already here since 1999
but then what year were you two married
i know you said 18 years 2003.
okay so you moved here shortly after to
be with him
yeah okay was it a couple weeks after
getting married or months so in in
april of 2002
we had the uh
you know the nikah it's like equivalent
of going to the court and getting
married here
yeah and then the reception was in
january of 2003
so that's and then you know a week or
ten days
after that reception which i had
traveled to pakistan for
we both flew back okay between though
april and january
were you two i guess separated
doing distance or knowing that you were
betrothed
yes it was what do we call a
long-distance relationship
yeah um so i was in pakistan and he was
in the states
and so we were just getting to know each
other through
through phone or through email um or
that back then there was like
chat rooms like msn chat
it was a good time yeah so we were just
you know it's like cautiously getting to
know each other
um but uh i think it was really after
um getting married like after the
reception moving in with him that's when
our
relationship really started got it
perfect thank you so much for
sharing all of this with me i really
appreciate it of course